[Music]
we're gonna do things different we're
gonna become a good person I just got
out of jail but in there for 30 years
but you get knocked in for killing
[Music]
killing one - stealin already hurry up
go move it
stealin horse they even done it all
I'm sleeping officer you can swag around
all you want but you're still a kid my
own business we're always short of food
why are you doing this that there's no
pants antagonizing [ __ ] all right
I could teach you to waste you join my
posse
[Music]
all right toss you up my friend [ __ ]
sorry my dude likes to say knock word
[Music]
they both just ran their fan in the
hamper so what do you do for fun crawl
around in the mud at all oh I feel so
good of my skin oh my bare bottom you
call it
[Music]
oh good god no oh Jesus Christ oh I can
hear this one other few minutes you're
in love you guys see my lamp all right
let's go John you banned the road for
too long you're losing it John John oh
my god boy stop reading well that's
enough family time for me it's been real
next seen packing up workers well we
killed the devil one more time
[Music]